I remember reading fear and loathing in
las vegas probably when I was 15 14 my
older was when one of my older brothers
books and I took it and started to read
it and you know I didn't get it at all
it was way over my head but I liked it
you know I really liked it and the bats
and and all just there's there's an John
O'Brien's book you know it is just
heartbreaking especially when you know
that the end the man came to and some of
the things his sister is a writer who's
written about him a fair amount and some
of its just heart just it makes you want
to just collapse and collapse because
it's just heartbreaking but a lot of
writers in the past 10 years have put
moments of books in Las Vegas DeLillo
just last year put part of falling man
there and heard Anderson's turn of the
century and William Bowman's the royal
family off the top of my head these are
three there quick fiction run through
there and I think part of it is that it
at this moment or in the past 10 years
it's become it's all of pop culture all
of the American trait for instant
gratification and all the we want it now
and we want the bigger badder faster
louder thing Vegas has is you know has
crystallized it and that makes it
interesting for anyone to come and and
and and check out and that also makes it
interesting for me as a for me that was
a starting point and then there is what
what are the lives of the people who
keep this going who live in love and
have all the hopes and dreams that all
of us do
in and who are keeping this industry
alive